hi I'm Li mayor and franchise game
director on Codemasters f1 2020 f1 2020
is the official video game of the 2020
Formula One World Championship the game
will feature all 20 official Formula One
drivers or feature all 10 of the
official Formula One teams and will also
contain all 22 of the tracks that would
make up the f1 twenty20 World
Championship the game will also contain
the 2019 formula two championship along
with the drivers and team that took part
in that series as well as the 12 race
event calendar so with Formula One being
an annual franchise for asset
codemasters every year we always looking
to bring something new something
exciting to the series and this year
that big headline feature is my team so
what's my team my team is your
opportunity to be the 11th team on the
grid your chance to create your own
Formula One team and go up against the
current Giants of Formula One so before
you get the opportunity to hit the track
you need to create your team so you want
to pick yourself a livery that's
appealing to you and then create a badge
which you can use to represent your team
these are important to see to your
team's identity once you're out on track
then every Formula One team needs
funding so the first thing you'll do is
to select a primary sponsor that primary
sponsor will provide the funding to then
allow you to build the rest of your team
so next up it's going to be the power
unit so you need to select a power unit
from of the official formula 1 power
unit suppliers and then you need a
second driver you can't have it for me
the 1 team without a teammate so you'll
then move to the driver market you'll
get the opportunity to hire a driver
from the formula 2 season
which you're happy with the look of your
team and that you've got a package that
you think will have you fighting for
victories you'll then move on to the
first press interview that you have in
the game and that's presented by Formula
One reporter will Buxton the questions
that will ask will also have impact on
the direction of development of your
first season's vehicle so if you answer
in such a way as to comment on you think
you've got a very strong power unit then
that department will be slightly
upgraded when you begin your my team
playthrough and then from this point on
you'll get a cinematic car reveal and
your cars revealed to the rest of the
world
and then Winchell cards been revealed to
the world it's time to start managing
things so in f1 2020 there's a myriad of
things that the play will need to manage
so first up there's a season timeline in
here you'll be managing things that a
Formula One team boss would also have to
handle so how do you manage the time and
the disciplines around the the team so
it could be I want to send a driver off
to do some driver training that's great
it'll give them a boost my team mate
will be a more accomplished driver but
meanwhile he may be neglecting something
else so it may be that he's not able to
do some press activities and press
activities would bring in sponsor
benefits so we'd get additional funding
for the team how you balance this
timeline and the activities that the
team and the drivers and the departments
have to take part in will determine how
success for your team will be coming
Formula One as all of these things
generate income they generate motivation
for the departments and they can assist
with the R&D departments as well and
speaking a little bit more about the R&D
in the game developing the car is
obviously a large part of the research
and development system but it's also the
facilities that the player now has to
develop and manage and amongst those are
aerodynamics chassis powertrain and
durability all four of which go to have
an impact on the overall performance of
the vehicle but a Formula One team is
much bigger than that so we also have
personnel and marketing personnel will
obviously help you to train your second
driver to make them more of a presence
on track and more successful a marketing
will help you when it comes to brokering
deals with new sponsors and trying to
get the best deal for your team and
talking about deals the games get a
fully fledged contract system so when
you go into the driver market now to
negotiate for another driver you have to
negotiate against the other teams or
even if I want to redeem retain the
driver which I've got at the moment I
still have to negotiate with that driver
and the additional money that those
drivers have they can then spend on
perks which are buffs for their
performance so they are constantly
evolving and constantly developing with
you and your team at the driver market
in f1 2020 will not only contain drivers
from the formula 2 Series but obviously
from the Formula One series as well so
as you become more successful you can
start looking at very high-end drivers
of course then
just going to join your team because you
want them or because you've got the
funding to bring them in they're gonna
want a car that can win as well so it's
important that your team has the level
of acclaim that that driver requires
that level of facilities that that
driver requires if for example I
approached Charles Leclerc and he's
expecting an engine facility at level 3
chassis at level 3 and that's the
absolute minimum he'll accept and I'm
not at those levels then the
negotiations are going to fall down
straightaway so there's multiple ways
that the player has to manage their
performance throughout the game and how
they engage with not only the drivers
but also in the driver market and how
they acquire those second drivers within
the game and of course you can't have a
driver market without being able to rate
drivers and this is a new feature of f1
2020 we've worked very closely with the
technical team at Formula One and we've
derived a wide variety of stats that
we've used to give accurate statistics
for how we think each drivers should be
rated within the game each drivers rated
on their experience their race craft
their awareness out on track and their
pace and this gives you a great starting
point to understand what sort of value
for money you're going to get from a
driver what sort of level of performance
you're going to get and is the basis of
the driver market these statistics will
also be updated throughout the course of
the season based on the drivers
real-world performances out on track the
player can obviously choose whether they
wish to take those stats of data today
game or not as it may be that during
their career the driver market has
actively moved those drivers statistics
around based on how they've performed
and how the teams they've driven for
have developed those drivers
so that's a little bit of insight into
the big new game mode in f1 2020 and of
course we've still got the career mode
as we've always had in the series
something which we would continue to
expand upon this year bringing in new
changes to the R&D system and a new
brush mechanic on how items are
developed we've also brought over some
of the driver market but obviously that
works slightly differently in driver
career because you're a driver not a
team boss as well so you're a commodity
so it's important that you obviously
have a good value in the driver market
but expanding a little bit on some of
the other err other areas of the game
which we've worked hard on this year
we've always found that Formula One's
are loved by so many people but it's a
very daunting prospect to sometimes play
it is actually a very hard
punishing on track experience for a lot
of people they see the sport they see
the game they love it but they can't
play the game at 11 they would choose to
so we've added a new accessibility
feature to the game this year and this
goes as far as removing the off track
punishing surfaces so gravels no longer
punishing getting stuck on the grass
losing the traction those things are
removed we've also simplified the
options menus because again formal ones
are a technical game and we wanted it to
be more accessible to people that we're
finding that a little bit off-putting
and then back to the on track we've also
added an automatic reset to track you
know we were seeing players occasionally
go completely off down a dead end at
tracks such as backu and then having to
do a three-point turn to get back onto
the circuit so that's now covered in
autumn
research track and then finally for the
most heavy-handed of the assists is the
AI Auto steering for the player
so this assists the player with their
steering to help them navigate the
circuit and race more cleanly so put
together these will actually broaden the
appeal of the game to any Formula one
fan who wishes to play the game and with
us making such great strides and
accessibility we thought this was the
perfect opportunity to bring
split-screen back to the series this is
something that we haven't had this
generation and it's something that the
fans have been asking for for some time
so we thought this was the perfect
opportunity to put in that to play a
shared experience playing split-screen
in Grand Prix mode so hopefully it'll be
something that really gets players
playing together allows that person who
maybe can't race against their friends
because they're not so skilled at the
game to be able to race because we have
the accessibility and to allow more
people to really engage with the game
and enjoying what Formula 1 has to offer
then also slightly related you know
trying to broaden the appeal of the game
and allow people to play the game the
way they choose to play we've also got
the option this year to change the
length of the season so previously you
would have a full Formula One season now
the player has the opportunity to do a
ten race season and pick the track that
they wish to race the 16 race season or
the full 22 race for beadalon calendar
this is fantastic for players who have
another limited number of favorite
tracks maybe or are slightly more time
limited and don't have the time to do a
full 22 race season or also just for
those people who literally want to skip
Monaco because such a challenging mo
beautiful circuit and while I mentioned
in circuits that transitions nicely into
the two new circuits that we've got in
the game this year so the first one
being zandvoort zandvoort is a beautiful
track based in netherlands set on a
beach location it's a very old-school
Formula one track it's a huge amount of
work this year to bring it up to modern
format along standards including the
inclusion of a very unique banked corner
something which we haven't seen in
Formula one for some time that should
produce some incredibly exciting racing
you know in a beautiful location when it
does get the opportunity to be driven in
the sport and then we also got handling
which in contrast is a very different
style of circuit this is a Street track
set in a city it's very much taking in
the geometry and the geography of the
area and this one obviously has a very
striking look as well it's got some huge
straights as well with massive braking
zones so I think we will witness some
incredible overtaking moves into those
and then the rest of the track is our
very technical
and high-speed flowing circuit so that's
a high-level overview of the cool new
feature that we've added to f1 2020 but
I also want to touch upon something
we've added which is a new deluxe
addition to the game as well and this
features Michael Schumacher obviously a
a true racing legend so amongst this
pack we've added the Jordan one line one
which is often touted as one of the most
beautiful Formula one cars ever it's
also the first car that Michael
Schumacher drove in Formula one we've
also got the Benetton 194 and the
Benetton b19 5 Michael Schumacher taking
his first championships in those cars
and then we also included the Ferrari f1
2000 which was the car that began
Ferraris dominance through that period
in Formula One
it's not just the cars at the star of
this pack we've also got some really
beautiful race suits that are inspired
by Michael Schumacher we also have
helmets and wonderful car liveries as
well
you'll also get a unique podium emot--
as well is that something new value to
the game this year as well the ability
to celebrate on the podium with a unique
animation that you choose to apply to
your character and finally to wrap
things up this is also the 70th
anniversary of Formula One so available
as pre-order you'll be able to get the
70th anniversary edition of the game and
in this will be some extra unique
customization content for the player to
apply to their driver and their car so
there'll be a new race seat for the
driver a new helmet vehicle skin badge
but also a cool new podium a moat which
you can apply to your character so you
can have that unique celebration when
climbing onto the podium and celebrating
all of those victories
[Music]
don't really hope you've enjoyed that
very brief insight into what we've done
with f1 2020 this year the game will be
out on July the 10th and they'll be
available on Xbox one ps4 PC and for the
first time Google stadia so thank you
very much for watching